vous pouvez le voir sur ces images le
futur centre d'entraînement du paris
saint germain est en train de prendre
forme
on peut commencer à avoir de la
végétation des bâtiments commence
également à sortir de terre une piste
cyclable a en parallèle était construite
à côté bref depuis le lancement des
travaux
le 29 février dernier les équipes
travaillent on écoute jean claude blanc
le directeur général délégué du psg nous
l'avions rencontré en septembre dernier
il ya énormément de machines qui sont
sur le site à poissy pour créer les
trois grandes plateformes sur lesquelles
nous viendrons construire le centre de
formation pour les jeunes et le centre
d'entraînement pour les professionnels
et donc les construction des bâtiments
eux-mêmes devraient démarrer dans le
courant de l'année 2021 pour s'achever
au début de l'année 2000 23 au total le
futur training center va faire 74
hectares il comprendra 17 terrains de
football dont un couvert il devrait
également y avoir un stade de 5000
places 150 sportifs de haut niveau
seront sur le site quotidiennement
le coût total plus de 200 millions
d'euros le prix d'un joueur comme neymar
un grégory un beau projet pour la ville
qui a dû batailler pour l'obtenir le psg
hésité à quitter saint germain en laye
lieux associés à l'histoire du club de
la capitale les jeux voire était au camp
des loges depuis à 1970 il était même au
camp des loges avant de jouer au parc
des princes 1 grégory qui était alors en
travaux à cette époque dès leur arrivée
en 2011 les qataries ont évoqué ce futur
training center plusieurs sites est
évoqué comme l'île de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines ou encore la commune
de thiverval grignon dans les yvelines
mais les dirigeants ont finalement opté
en 2016 pour cette zone située au bord
de la nationale 13 tout près de
l'autoroute a13 et du centre hospitalier
intercommunal on écoute les réactions
c'est un projet qui valorise le
territoire avant de valoriser la seule
ville de poissy
à voir le paris saint germain sur 75
hectares avec 1000 emplois pendant la
durée des travaux 2 millions d'euros de
taxes annuelles pour la communauté
urbaine
oui c'est juste c'est juste exceptionnel
faut bien comprendre que une marque
comme le psg savoir quelle est la
implanté dans les yvelines aura un
retentissement international
c'est une publicité à zéro euro
donc c'est fait quelque chose de
formidable mais à quoi va servir ce
training center il va surtout regrouper
la plupart des sections du paris
saint-germain en un seul et unique lieu
on écoute jean claude blanc il est
important comme dans tous les grands
clubs européens pour noter le paris
saint-germain d'infrastructures qui
permettent de s'entraîner dans
l'excellence de faire progresser les
jeunes de créer cette mécanique
aspirationnel et donc à terme d'avoir
dans l'équipe de plus en plus de jeunes
qu'ils sont innés qui seront in et de la
formation du paris saint germain
en tout cas les dirigeants à qatari la
ville de poissy ont déjà commencé à
ancrer le training center dans
l'histoire du psg la nouvelle voie
d'accès s'appellera gris et geek récent
un homme d'affaires qui a participé à la
création du club en 1970 il a été
d'ailleurs le premier président il est
décédé en 1996 à l'âge de 76 ans